good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight there is a new congress
here in washington but the government
shutdown continues as before the
stalemate over border wall funding
entered its third week each side is
betting the other will give in first
negotiations continue at the White House
today but apparently they bore no fruit
because afterward the president emerged
that say the situation on our southern
border is so grave he may be forced to
build a wall without congressional
approval have you considered using
emergency powers to grant yourself
authorities to build this wall without
congressional approval and second guess
I have to go you have yes I have and I
can do it if I want so you don't need
congressional approval to build no we
can use them absolutely we can call a
national emergency because of the
security of our country absolutely no we
can do it I haven't done it I may do it
I may do it but we could call a national
emergency and build it very quickly
well Democrats call that extremism but
who are the extremists here well the
ones who refuse to defend their country
the new Speaker of the House has
announced that the Democratic Congress
will never under any circumstances
allocate a single tax dollar to build
the border wall not because it's too
expensive obviously these are the
Democrats but because a wall would
violate some previously unknown and
never explained moral code watch it's
not who we are as a nation
it's an old way of thinking well it's
tempting to assume that the speaker must
have misspoke in there but it's hardly
the first time she has said that immoral
immorality she's used those words
repeatedly now Pelosi is the highest
ranking Democrat in the United States
she's a leader of her parties so we
should not blow this off we should take
it seriously as a matter of policy
Democrats believe a border wall is
immoral and that raises the question
what do they consider moral well
American troops stuck forever in Syria
for one thing that's just fine sex
selective abortions paid for with tax
dollars kicking up more moral than that
and Tifa riding in the streets all
perfectly virtuous and it turns out even
walls can be
morale under the right circumstances
they just can't protect America
Democrats gladly signed off on border
defenses for Jordan Tunisia and Israel
no problem glad to do it but here on
behalf of our own people no Americans
don't deserve that they're immoral for
asking those are the parameters of their
morality so what religion is this
exactly joining us now to explain his
archbishop Chris Hahn he's an attorney
radio host and former Haeju center Chuck
Schumer and he joins us tonight
so if you would I think we've talked
about this before
Nate suppose he has repeatedly called
the wall immoral and at first I thought
well you know she talks a lot and I know
the feeling sometimes you miss peek but
this is a talking point this is
something she's saying intentionally is
the leader now officially of your party
so Democrats believe border walls are
immoral what does that mean I don't
think she means it in the good versus
evil type of morality but rather this is
a colossal waste of money
since there's never been a ladder in a
rope that hasn't beaten a wall I'm
finished I will let you finish but I
just want to back up I promise I'm not I
don't mean to interrupt you but I just
want to Beca know what other sense of
immoral is there I mean by definition
immoral describes something that is not
moral it is again by definition within
the scheme of morality it's a religious
precepts so what does that mean I was
walling I look I mean I don't think he
means it in a good versus evil religious
way I think she means it anyway is that
this is a colossal estupid this is a
colossal II stupid thing to build when a
guy with a ladder that's a foot taller
and a rope to get down the other side
will beat it and quite frankly know
you're by the NR okay get a book of the
NRA argument though if we put a wall up
to block out illegal you know people
from ku come here to want to harm us
people who want to come here legally or
the only ones are gonna be stopped by
that wall because people are gonna come
here illegally or come here to harm us
or gonna figure a way around it just
like they figure out a way to get guns
they're gonna they're gonna get there oh
my god I think I think I'm following you
so they're gonna get their own wall
they're gonna buy a wall on the black
market and bring their wall to our wall
and beat it is that what you're saying
just to continue the metaphor
No law-abiding people will be stopped by
the wall but the people who wish to
break our laws will be will avoid the
wall like you ever like that's the right
argument for you in prison that's the
right dog for guns it's the right it
should be it should be accepted here -
ok I'm trying to take you seriously is
that also true at prisons which are
surrounded by walls walls meant to keep
lawbreakers in do they not work so you
know a prison is a couple of acres and
you've got centuries pointed that can
monitor that wall the president's
talking about thousands of miles of wall
are we gonna have sentries every hundred
y'all every hundred feet to watch that
wall look we'd be better off Tucker we'd
be better off with modern technology
we've used drones we can use other
things to monitor the border make sure
it's backed up by the appropriate masses
we're a border patrol Kentucky I'm
trying to get reasonable make sense we
we both know that you're in favor of
more people coming here illegally and
I'm not and that's the actual debate but
for the purpose of security of course
we're not but I just want to drill down
a little bit on this idea of morality
because I think it's really important
when the leader of a political party
starts calling the other side in moral
that's not a small thing so I just want
to understand in the very same day that
she said that she pushed to allow
taxpayer dollars from the United States
to go abroad to fund abortions in Latin
America among other places so you're
saying it's immoral to keep Latin
America out with a wall but it's not
immoral to pay for Latin American
abortions that's what Nancy Pelosi you
say do you agree with that
well you know I think we need like a
couple of hours to discuss the weight
which is building up a foghorns in other
countries I'm just wondering so I'm not
going to first of all tax dollars do not
pay for abortions of their country and
the challenge which we all know about so
they will never they will never go that
way right but I mean debating whether or
not that's moral immoral that's a longer
conversation we probably switch still
hold on well it's just I'm not asking
you to conduct theology here I'm just
asking you to give me your view if the
two things taxpayer money for sex
selective
portions which nan suppose c is for okay
or building a wall ones immoral which
not is it I don't I don't believe that
she's for sex selective abortion she is
for and I think the more moral use of
the funding for the wall would be to fix
the bridges and roads that are crumbling
in this country that actually need
repair and spend a couple of bucks on
ring video doorbell for border security
is really not as big of a problem as the
president in the world the president
making a problem that doesn't exist okay
so really quick at the very same time
again that she was pushing against
America's ability to defend itself and
its borders and for more taxpayer-funded
abortions in other countries
she was also pushing for more foreign
aid for other countries some of which
would go to border security we've
already funded with her approval border
secured including walls in a bunch of
other countries why were those not
immoral but our wall is immoral well you
know when we talk about the Israeli wall
and other countries that have walls like
that they are in a constant state of war
with their neighbor we are not in a
state of no or we know that's like oh we
are not having a crisis at the border
people not lobbing bombs into our
country from from Mexico back their
trading partner right I understand that
and there are a number of barriers in
Israel and some of them are designed to
keep terrorists from coming in and I
don't think anyone would question the
right to do that good for them right but
there's also a barrier on the southern
border of Israel with Egypt that is
designed solely to keep immigrants from
Africa out of their country now I think
it's Israel's right to build that wall I
would never contest that I don't have a
problem with it but Nancy Pelosi doesn't
have a problem with it either
that was not immoral but our wall is
immoral I'd honestly don't understand
that what is the answer you know we're
we're a nation of immigrants it's what
makes this country great
it's what refreshes this country gives
us a competitive edge with the rest of
the world if the President and his party
want to change that that should be what
they talk about but there's there right
now is demagoguing about some invisible
traffic does not exist at the southern
border and it's time for them to shut
out and face reality and even the
government and have a conversation about
who your teacher how many people are
here illegally now in the united states
I would think over 10 million over 10
and 14 million try over 20 which is the
latest estimate and not from some
right-wing organization but from Ivy
League researchers does that seem like a
lot does that seem like the current
border security schemes are working to
you over 20 million P it seems like a
lot and it seems like a lot and and and
90% of those people Tucker did not cross
the southern border they understand a
visa you don't even know with him Tamara
lien how many are here every I wasn't
prepared for that question but every I
see Fred shows every Ivy League study
that I've read about this topic says
that exact same thing that most people
who are here illegally have just
overstayed their visas and building a
wall at the southern border is not going
to change that it's just a colossal
waste no money if you believe the money
is amoral then it's really not here
we're just guessing it's not gonna work
okay maybe right we'll see Chris thank
you very much all right